>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Fred Augustyn: It
is my pleasant task
to introduce Callista Gingrich
the author of several books,
four so far on Ellis the
Elephant featuring him.
In any case including
"Sweet Land of Liberty"
about American exceptionalism,
"Land of the Pilgrim's Pride"
about colonial America both were on
the New York Times Best Seller list
of children's picture books.
"Yankee Doodle Dandy" is
about the American Revolution,
"From Sea to Shining Sea" is about
the expedition of Lewis and Clark
and the early years
of the United States.
"Christmas in America" is about
the history of that holiday
and was released in October, 2015.
There is a pattern here.
Callista if I may so address
her is very much interested
in American history and the
cause of freedom in the world
and that accounts for many of
her, much of her work on history
and public policy documentaries.
She's multi-talented
and a multi-tasker.
Long interest in music which was
her major in college Callista sings
in the choir at the Basilica
of the National Shrine
of the Immaculate Conception
in Washington,
D.C. Many people probably know.
It's right near the Catholic
University of America.
Originally from Wisconsin she is of
Polish descent on her father's side
and the Polish connection led to
my meeting her several years ago
which I remember very
fondly, four years ago.
She was at a bipartisan event to get
out the vote among Polish Americans
and the President of
that organization,
the American Polish Advisory Council
is retired General Edward Roney then
95 years old but still with us
thankfully and she and her husband,
Newt Gingrich who is a writer in
his own right talked about one
of their trips to Poland and they
did a documentary on the first trip
to Poland by the Pope
John Paul II in 1979.
And at that time I said to
myself what a nice person she is.
And somebody who generally enjoys
talking to and looking about people
and I'm sure that you will agree
with me so it is my privilege
to introduce author, musician and
documentarian Callista Gingrich here
to talk about her role as a
writer of children's books.
[Applause]
>> Callista Gingrich: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Come on over Ellis.
Well, good morning.
It's wonderful to be
here with you today.
My name is Callista Gingrich
and this is my very special
friend Ellis the Elephant.
Ellis is a very smart
and very fun elephant.
He loves to read books,
don't you Ellis?
And I know that many of
you love to read books
as well that's why we're all here
at the National Book Festival.
Now, Ellis loves to read
about American history
and has had many, many adventures.
In my first book "Sweet Land
of Liberty" Ellis learns
about what makes America special.
In "Land of the Pilgrims
Pride" he learns
about the pilgrims
and colonial America.
In "Yankee Doodle Dandy" Ellis
learns about our patriots
and the American Revolution.
In "From Sea to Shining Sea" he
learns about the Wild, Wild West
and the great expedition
of Lewis and Clark.
And in "Christmas in
America" Ellis learns
about how Christmas has been
celebrated throughout our
nation's history.
Do any of you like Christmas?
Yes, well and snow too.
Excellent.
Well Ellis likes Christmas too.
Well today we are going
to join Ellis as he learns
about something very,
very important.
In my new book "Hail to
the Chief" Ellis learns
about our American presidents
and discovers how they've led our
country throughout American history.
Now, who knows who our president is?
Who is our president?
Anybody know?
Our president is President
Obama of course
and where does our president live?
Anybody.
>> In the White House.
>> The White House exactly.
And who was our very
first president?
>> Washington.
>> Yes. It was George Washington.
That is exactly right.
Now in "Hail to the Chief" Ellis
is going to learn about some
of our most important and
influential presidents and I am
so excited to share this
book with you today.
But first I want to talk about why
it's so important for you to learn
about our American
presidents with Ellis.
Now in a just a few weeks
our country will vote
for our 45th president.
This is a very big decision and it's
going to impact our entire nation
and someday all of you kids are
going to be able to vote as well.
Now to vote you'll have to
understand what the presidency means
and what better way to do so
than by learning about some
of our greatest presidents.
This is what you can do
with Ellis the Elephant.
In "Hail to the Chief" you'll
learn that the President
of the United States is one of
the most important elected leaders
in the world and that he or she
represents our entire nation.
You'll learn that many
different kinds
of people have become president
each with their unique strengths,
perspectives and weaknesses.
And finally you'll
learn that any American
from any background can
grow up to become President
of the United States and have
the chance to change history.
Now we have never had an
elephant as president before.
And Ellis I don't think we ever will
so unfortunately President
Ellis might be
out of the question
but you know what?
Anyone of you could grow
up to be the President
of the United States just like the
presidents in this book have done.
Isn't that right Ellis?
This is the first time
I've ever read this book
to anyone including Ellis so,
let's read "Hail to the Chief"
and I hope you'll enjoy it.
And if some of you children
want to come up a little closer
so you can see the pictures in
the book that would be great.
Come on up.
There's lots of room for everybody.
Let's switch places Ellis.
Yeah. All right.
It's great to see so
many of you here today.
Wow what a great looking group.
Isn't it Ellis?
Yes. All right.
All right it looks like
we're all ready to go and I'm
so happy to see all of you here.
So the book is called "Hail to
the Chief" and you can see Ellis
on the cover with some of our other
presidents and the dedication says,
"Dedicated to our American
presidents
who have led this exceptional
nation.
"The American president
has a great task,
a job as exciting as
anyone could ask.
Elected to uphold America's
laws the Commander
in Chief defends freedom's cause.
Ellis the elephant knew our country
was blessed with exceptional leaders
who stood up to the test.
He was eager to meet the
presidents of the past
and learn how they
governed a nation so vast."
Ellis is in the portrait gallery
in this illustration with some
of our very first presidents.
"Ellis had heard of George
Washington before the man
who led the Revolutionary War.
After the war it was
General Washington's fate
to lead the new nation
he fought to create.
As president, Washington was ready
to serve defending the
freedoms he pledged to preserve.
Our country's first leader
set the standard indeed
for future presidents who
would follow his lead.
Here's George Washington
at his inauguration our
very first president."
That was an exciting moment Ellis.
"Thomas Jefferson was a
Founding Father of our nation.
He wrote of independence
in a famous declaration.
With clarity and passion this
document explained how our God-given
rights must always be maintained.
As president, Jefferson
had a grand vision
and boldly made an
important decision.
His Louisiana Purchase
added new land
and opened the West
for America to expand."
And here is Ellis with
Lewis and Clark and they're
with President Jefferson and where
does President Jefferson live?
Monticello.
Not any more.
He used to.
"Known as the father
of the Constitution James Madison
drafted a brilliant solution.
As president, Madison
had challenges galore
when a British invasion
took our country to war.
At the Battle of Baltimore Ellis had
no doubt we'd win the War of 1812
and kick the British out.
Here the Star Spangled Banner
waved high for all to see
and inspired our anthem
by Francis Scott Key."
Do some of you know the
Star Spangled Banner?
>> Yeah.
>> Callista Gingrich:
Yeah that's great.
"Andrew Jackson captured
the public's admiration.
A man of the people with a
strong reputation he vowed
to remember his own humble start and
took every American's need to heart.
But Jackson learned the
challenge of fame and success
when his inaugural party
became a real mess.
Thousands crowded the
White House and made
such a clamor a major departure
from its usual glamor."
Look at the White House
and how crazy things got
at Andrew Jackson's inaugural party.
There's even an eagle swinging
from the chandelier and I've got
to share something with you.
In all of these illustrations
there's an eagle and so
when you're reading these
books you'll always want
to look for the eagle.
And the eagle represents our freedom
and independence that we have
in this beautiful country.
So we'll always look for the eagle.
"Abraham Lincoln bravely and
wisely presided over a nation
in crisis and deeply divided.
A fight over slavery
caused the country to split
and the Civil War started
when the south tried to quit.
The conflict was awful
and took a great toll
so at Gettysburg wrote
and rose to console.
The Union army fought
long and hard to ensure
that this fragile young
nation could long endure."
There's President Lincoln
at Gettysburg.
>> I see the eagle.
>> Callista Gingrich:
Do you see the eagle?
Yes. There he is with
President Lincoln.
Do you see the eagle?
>> I see it.
>> Callista Gingrich:
You see the eagle too.
That's right.
"America was filled with many
beautiful places with mountains
and valleys and wide open spaces.
President Teddy Roosevelt
cherished conservation and wanted
to preserve the best
land for the nation.
Roosevelt set aside
millions of acres of land
and traveled the country
to see them firsthand.
On one camping trip he
couldn't help but remark,
on the beauty of Yosemite
National Park."
>> I see the eagle again.
>> Callista Gingrich:
There's Teddy Roosevelt
and there's the eagle with Teddy.
Have any of you been
to a national park?
Probably so.
Ellis have you been
to a national park?
All right.
"As President Woodrow Wilson
decided to send U.S. soldiers
to bring World War I to an end,
when all sides agreed the
fighting would cease he sought
to ensure a long-lasting peace.
Ellis learned that Wilson
advanced a greater cause
that all nations would agree
to the same set of laws.
In Paris he argued for a new
organization an international body
called the League of Nations."
>> I see the eagle.
>> Callista Gingrich: There's
the eagle and there's Ellis
with President Wilson in Paris.
Does anybody recognize
the Eiffel Tower in Paris?
Yes. It is, it is and our President
Woodrow Wilson went to France
to Paris to work on this particular
body called the League of Nations.
"Before long World
War II suddenly began
and Franklin D. Roosevelt
was just the right man.
He spoke out so the American
people could hear that through war
and hardship they had
nothing to fear.
Through fireside chats he
shared America's plight
and gave people the courage
to continue to fight.
Month by month Allied Forces pushed
on to Berlin certain this was the
struggle they'd eventually win."
>> I see the eagle.
>> Callista Gingrich: And here's
the eagle and here Ellis is
with FDR, President Roosevelt.
He was our President during World
War II and he has his dog with him.
His dog was named Fala
and there's Fala and Ellis
with President Roosevelt.
Do you see the dog?
That was a cute dog.
"At long last the Second
World War was won
but America's job was not yet done.
Communism threatened
freedom once more
and this Ellis learned
was called the Cold War.
President Harry Truman
proposed an alliance
to unite the free nations
in strong defiance.
NATO agreement left many
impressed with the strength
and resolve of the unified west."
>> I see the eagle.
>> Callista Gingrich:
You see the eagle
and there Ellis is
with President Truman.
"General Dwight Eisenhower best
known as Ike was a president
that most Americans liked.
In World War II he earned
the people's respect
and soon won their
hearts as President-elect.
Ike made it his mission to plan
and create a nationwide
network of new interstates.
These wide open roads
kept America thriving
and Ellis imagined the
thrill of fast driving."
That's right there's the eagle
and can you imagine not having
interstates to drive on?
It's because of President Eisenhower
that we have this wonderful
interstate system now
and we can drive our cars on it.
"The early 1960s were a hopeful time
for a courageous leader
who served in his prime.
John F. Kennedy asked citizens
to volunteer to improve
and preserve the nation
they held dear.
Ellis was inspired by
Kennedy's bold themes
and how he challenged
Americans to dream big dreams.
He sent men to the moon within
a few short years to discover
and explore its vast new frontiers."
And here is President
Kennedy at his inauguration.
Yes and the eagle is there as well.
"Lyndon Johnson's years were
anything but calm with unrest
at home and war in Vietnam.
While the times made his job
especially tough President Johnson
did some important stuff.
With Martin Luther King
he fought discrimination
to keep a founding promise
of our great nation.
Together they were determined to
win crucial fights that guaranteed
to everyone equal civil rights.
>> I see the eagle next the Ellis.
>> Callista Gingrich: That's right
and here we have President Johnson
and Martin Luther King Jr.
Signing the Civil Rights Act.
That was quite a moment
wasn't it Ellis?
"Ronald Reagan had faith
in the American way knowing
that freedom not fear
would carry the day.
Ellis learned that Reagan
pursued one major goal
to liberate the world
from Soviet control.
Reagan went to Berlin
a city split in two
with one thing he insisted
the Soviets do.
When he called on their
leaders to tear
down this wall his words marked
the start of the Communist fall."
And there's Ellis with
President Reagan in Berlin.
>> I see the eagle.
>> Callista Gingrich:
You see the eagle.
Yeah he gets around.
He's everywhere in every
single illustration.
And I just want to add
that my illustrator Susan
Arciero is a very talented artist
and we worked together
on this series
and she really does a nice job.
"Thinking back on all the presidents
he observed Ellis was so grateful
for those who had served.
Throughout our history they
gave what was needed and strived
to ensure that our
country succeeded.
Each had accepted a great
responsibility and done the job
to the best of their ability.
Ellis had tremendous respect and
admiration for the presidents
who had led this exceptional
nation."
>> I see the eagle.
I see the eagle.
>> Callista Gingrich: The end.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you.
Well I hope you enjoyed that because
Ellis and I certainly enjoyed being
with you today and before we go
we'll come just down off the stage
and if you'd like the meet
Ellis give him a high five,
have a picture.
Would you like that?
All right let's do that Ellis.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.